SWEET SONG: Hi, everyone.
Thanks for coming to
our talk today doing
apps for the Chrome
OS ecosystem.
My name is Sweet.
And I'm a product manager for
Android apps on Chrome OS.
For today's session,
we're going to cover
three different topics.
The first is an update on our
Chrome OS ecosystem growth.
The second, we're
going to be introducing
the cool new features
that we've been working
on, and lastly, developer
notes and best practices
to enhance your
experience on Chrome OS.
So starting off with
our ecosystem update
for our Chrome OS growth--
Chrome OS devices
run Android apps
through the Play Store
using an Android container.
But we are inherently
different from a lot
of the traditional
Android phones, in that we
have a larger screen.
We also have different
inputs, including
keyboard, mouse, stylus.
Users also use more
multi-monitor support with us.
And they tend to use a
lot more multitasking,
with multiple windows
and activities going on
at the same time.
So as the leading OS for
Google's large screen
experiences, we've been
really doubling down
to provide the hardware
that's capable of doing
all these wonderful things.
In addition to the clam
shells, the convertibles,
and the Chrome
boxes, this past year
we've launched our very first
tablets and attachables.
But as we have more of a
device hardware corpus,
we've also seen
more users, as well.
In Q4 of 2018, 21% of all
notebooks sold in the US
were Chromebooks.
That's a 23% year over year
growth over our last year.
We're currently in nine
countries and physically
in more than 10,000 stores.
And we're continuing that
expansion this year as well.
So we have our device portfolio.
We have more users.
But also, users are responding
more to apps in Chrome OS.
In the last year, app usage
on Android on Chrome OS
has grown by 4x.
And that's a testament to
our growing app catalog,
along with users finding
more utility and better
experiences on their Chrome
OS devices from the apps.
There's two that I
really want to highlight.
The first one is Asphalt
8, a racing car game.
We work with them to really
enhance the experience
on our Chrome OS devices,
specifically around keyboard
support and tablet mode.
And we found that, after
these improvements,
they've seen a 6x
boost in daily activity
and a 9x boost in app revenue.
We've been really
proud of these numbers.
And we've been working with
them on Asphalt 9, which
is in our retail mode
in physical stores
as well to show off.
The other app is Concepts,
which we just saw in our video
just now.
Concepts is an illustrating app.
And it's really
well-positioned with Chrome OS
because we have a really
fast and responsive stylus
along with a larger screen
real estate on our devices,
so users can IDA more.
Compared to the other devices,
we've seen that on Chrome OS
they've had 12x more time
spent and double the paid
conversions.
And on our higher-end devices,
for the Pixelbooks and Pixel
Slates, it's even better,
with 20x more time
spend and quadruple
the paid conversions.
And those are just
two examples of apps
that we've been working
with our developers.
And they've seen
users embrace them.
And we're happy to work with you
as well to promote and really
make your apps
shine on Chrome OS.
As an added bonus, your apps
improved for Chrome OS are also
going to benefit from those
on Android foldable phones
and Android tablets.
So you get more bang
for your buck, too.
Next, I'm going to turn it over
to Stefan Kuhne, one of our eng
leads, on what we've been
working on this past year.
STEFAN KUHNE: Hello, everyone.
I'm Stefan Kuhne.
I'm one of the tech leads
bringing Android to Chrome OS.
And you have maybe you
seen me in earlier talks.
And this brings me already to
what I'm talking about today--
well, all the changes we
have done over the past year
to this year.
So let's have a look.
First off, we are
launching Android Pie.
Well, it's a little bit
snow of yesterday, I know.
But the thing is,
we were actually
starting that conversion
process end of last year
with our Pixel Slate tablet.
And we are continuing to roll
out Pie to all of our fleet.
And, at the same
time, we are also
improving the quality,
stability, performance,
and all the other kind of things
over the course of this year.
At the same time, we are also
turning on Android P by default
on for most users, so
means for end users.
OK, so another
thing we have done
is we were doubling down
on improving the developer
quality.
So first off, there is
a one-click installer
for Android Studio.
Much less hassle than
before, you will definitely
agree on that one.
We improved also
the linting support,
which basically gives you
some kind of highlights where
you are doing something
which is possibly not
that ideal for Chrome OS.
So, basically, everything
what we tell you
is beneficial for the phone
as well as for the Chrome OS.
But in this
particular case, it's
of course especially for that.
Another thing what we are
doing is inside the Android--
no, inside the Linux VM, we
are adding audio support.
Which basically
means you are getting
all the audio which we used
to use on Linux directly
on the system.
Which means Udacity and
all these kind of things
are working.
So for the next
thing, I'm calling
to Emilie, who is actually
demonstrating how to improve--
well, how we have actually
used ADB now over USB.
EMILIE ROBERTS: Thanks, Stefan.
So I'm am super happy to
announce what we've added here.
Can we bump over
to the computer?
So here I have Android Studio
running on the Pixelbook--
whoops.
And I could run--
uh-oh, what have I done?
Agh-ha, OK.
Well I ran the app, and
it pushed it directly
to the device.
This is last year's news
if you were here last year.
So there's nothing
new with that.
But what is new--
and this does not
require developer mode.
So super exciting--
I've got pixel to phone.
I can plug it in over USB.
And this time actually,
let's do a profiling
just so you know
that I'm legit here.
In the bottom, you see
this Connect to Linux, So,
Allow Linux to
Access my USB device.
And if the demo Gods smile--
and they have smiled on me.
Google Pixel 2 XL
is right there.
So I can select the phone.
This will hopefully
run my profiler.
There we go.
The app is hopefully
working, please--
installing APKs.
Whoops, my screen
has fallen asleep.
So there's the app running.
You can see the profiling.
It's legit.
Yeah, you can clap, yeah.
Thank you, Stefan and your team.
And you can see it if I clack--
you get the screen, you know,
you get the screen tabs.
You can dig into the memory just
like you'd expect in profiling.
What can I say?
Thanks a lot.
I'll be back.
Don't worry.
Back to you, Stefan.
STEFAN KUHNE: Awesome teamwork.
Many thanks, Emilie.
OK, so another thing, we
know that you are actually
one of the power users of our
system because you have an IDE,
you have Android
applications, you
have Chrome, all these
other kind of things.
And one of the things what
you are really missing
is a virtual desktop.
So beginning with M76,
which is currently
in our Canary channel, you can
already test out this feature.
Simply go into Chrome's
Flex and turn it on.
Another thing what
we are doing is well,
in the past HDCP
was not reasonable
on the external monitor.
We have mitigated that.
You can now play back videos
on next on an external screen.
If you ever plan
to actually use--
for example, SurfaceView
setSecure, well be aware,
there are monitors which
are not supporting this.
And, of course, it's a very bad
experience for the user if he
sees only a black box
instead of buttons,
and cannot press anything.
So therefore, don't really
use it if you don't really
mean to use it.
Another thing what we
are doing is integration.
So a lot of integration
work was going, for example,
into ARCore, which is
in all our tablets,
which have world-facing cameras.
It's being used already
in schools for things
like Geogebra, and Google
Expedition, and many more
to follow.
Another thing what we are
doing is instant app support.
Instant app support
is ready to roll out.
And if your application
is doing this,
you will actually see
that very shortly.
I/O-- I have seen
this somewhere.
Well, this is
meant to be exactly
as meant, input and output.
So we have done various
things around IO.
One of them is
bringing some drives,
any kind of external
media to Chromebooks.
So when you plug it in,
the Android application
will be able to
access it directly.
So that was one of the
big asks from last year.
Another thing is play files.
So this is something which,
if you ever use the Chrome OS
files browser, you
have possibly seen
that there was no way
of accessing the Android
files if you want to send
something or inspect something.
Well, now inside this
tool, you have actually
also Play Files, which is
the mirror of SD cards.
So you can get to
all of these files.
Another thing is if you
have DocumentsProvider API,
like for example Google Drive,
Dropbox, or anything like that,
they will actually
be reflected now
also in the files application.
So, basically, it's
fully transparent
and it's running
inside Chrome space.
But it's using all the Android
features on that point.
So you can drag and drop
files now from all these cloud
storage providers without
thinking about that.
And if you are using
this cloud provider
API for your own
applications, you
can even then make it that you
can actually use this directly,
so like editing files and so on.
Managed devices-- we had
other several new add-ons.
So first off, we were improving
the installation speed
from minutes two seconds.
And it's also much more secure.
So therefore, it
should be now really
be installed when an
administrator is asking for it.
Another thing that
we are doing is
when you are using the VPN
connection from Chrome OS,
then Android will
automatically use the same VPN
connection, which is a
huge improvement in regards
of security.
So now I am coming to the
most important thing for you,
because this is a section
which is explicitly
trying to target all the
things that you should actually
watch out for to make your
application shine on Chrome OS.
So let's have a look.
Multi-monitor-- this is
not really new, right?
We were talking about this
one already last year.
But one of the things
what we were silently
doing behind the scenes was we
were doing a lot of scaling.
Because the thing is, if you
have an internal small monitor,
which has 4K, and you have
an external big screen, which
is maybe even also 4k, then
there an a size differential
of two to one.
Which basically means if you are
dragging a window from A to B,
suddenly it becomes
like a giant mess.
So, therefore, that is something
what the user doesn't really
want to see.
So therefore, what we do
is we scale that thing down
to match the same size
as on the notebook.
But the problem with that is,
of course, that well, scaling
means you are losing some
information from the thing,
it's getting blurry.
It's not really that great.
So therefore, what we are
trying to do going forward
is we will actually change
the density on the fly.
That is something
what we were talking
about last year and
the year before,
about changing the size.
So this is now the next thing--
which is the next and the last
thing that we are asking
anything from you--
is to actually make
your application be
aware of different densities
on an activity level.
So don't do that inside
your service or what-not.
Do it actually
inside the activity
because you might actually have
multiple windows on the screen,
and you never know
where it is, right?
So, if you're using
on-configuration changes,
check out the density.
And otherwise, listen
to these kind of events.
So gaming-- if you
were ever using gaming
and you were using
a game controller,
you have possibly noticed
that there is not really
much of what Android is doing.
So you cannot really figure
out how many controllers are
connected.
And if the mapping was
wrong, it didn't really work.
We are changing this.
Basically, very soon
you will actually
have the standard API,
which is on any phone.
So if you want to test it
out, test it on your phone.
If it's working there, it
will work in the future.
Well, then there's
relative mouse positioning,
which is used by all
kinds of first-person
shooters and whatnot.
We have that also
now supported, which
went out in M74, which
is now in release state.
So you can request the pointer.
And you can actually listen then
to all changes and go for that.
So and with that, I'm coming
to the most important topic
of this talk, which
is animation jank.
Well, if you were ever
doing any kind of animation,
you have possibly seen
kind some kind of jank.
What is jank?
It's something like when
something moves very slowly,
suddenly you see this kind of
hiccup when something is stuck
and then continuing.
And there is, unfortunately,
no tool up to now shows you
where this hiccup
is coming from.
But we were working
on that very hard.
So and for that, I have a
small presentation for that.
So, unfortunately,
this is not that easy.
There are a lot of boxes.
But don't be scared.
If you have never
seen them before,
I will actually guide
you through everything.
So, first off, when you look
into a standard application,
it is usually using
double buffering.
What does double buffering mean?
It means you have one
buffer, which is being shown,
and one buffer, which
is being rendered to.
And you are constantly iterating
between the two of them.
And the application
is basically--
it's getting the buffer, it's
rendering through the buffer,
and it's submitting the
buffer to be displayed.
And then it's doing
the same thing again,
and over, and over,
and over again.
It's always exactly
the same thing.
And, in screen space,
you see them first
the old picture, then comes
the vSync, which is basically
the end of the scan out
of the buffer, which
means at which point in time
you can flip to the next one.
And then it flips
to the next frame.
This is the ideal state.
So looking deeper into the
system, there's driver space.
So in driver space, we are
waiting now for the reasoning
from the previous frame so
that we can take the buffer
and render stuff into it.
So which is basically then
producing all the buff master
DMA commands and putting them
into one contiguous buffer
so that the GPU can read them,
and continuing the same thing.
And in GPU space, the GPU
was simply taking that thing,
it's executing these buffers
which were being produced
by the driver space, and
doing that one by one,
and flipping it automatically
via hardware event
into view as soon as is needed.
So, where comes
jank now into play?
Well, jank comes if, for
example, the rendering takes
much longer than you expect.
So in that case, what happens?
Well, basically you're
repeating the previous frame.
And even worse, whatever you
have already cued up in order
to be rendered is possibly
producing the next frame,
which is also bad.
So it's not only one frame
which is bad, it's two or three.
So therefore, it's really
a bad thing to have that.
So another thing what can
happen is that in user space,
you will actually see
something similar.
So which means like
for example, there
is memory swapping involved,
Chrome is basically
loading some new
notifications, or maybe Android
is doing some
compaction, or whatnot.
And in that case,
you might actually
end up in the same state.
But unfortunately, we are
running a desktop operating
system, right?
Which is not only that.
So now it's getting
a little bit more
complicated because we have
suddenly multiple clients which
have to be rendered.
So we have now n
things which are being
rendering at the same time.
So think about everything
what I was talking before,
but only n times.
So this case, two.
And we have a driver space
exactly as many boxes
again, only double.
And well, this GPU space
gets cramped, right?
Because we have to do
now multiple things,
which are [INAUDIBLE].
And, well, then comes the scary
thing, which is the compositor.
What is the compositor?
Well, basically it's now
taking all these surfaces
and it's compositing
them together
into one surface, which means we
have to read everything again,
write it again into the
output buffer, which
is another overhead, right?
So let's complete the
picture with some more boxes
from what happened before.
And now if you look
into the screen
and you look from the upper
left to the lower right,
you see that the blue thing is
percolating through the system
all the way to the output.
Except for, there is no blue
slide on the screen, right?
Which means we have already
created a pipeline here.
A pipeline is a good
thing in some ways.
Because the thing
is, if the system has
some fluctuations like
memory swapping or whatnot,
you can compensate for them.
But the thing is it
has also the problem
that if you click
something, it might actually
take a little bit of
time, additional time,
to actually see that.
So the good news is
there is actually
very old technology
from the 90s, which
is actually trying to eliminate
this by using overlays.
So overlays is basically
the GPU was reading out
two buffers at the same time
and it's blending them together.
But unfortunately,
that works only as long
as you are not zooming in or
you are not turning your display
into a portrait, for example.
And since most
users are possibly
playing around with
the zoom level,
it might actually not work.
The good news on the other
hand is we are working on it.
By the end of the year--
I hope much, much earlier--
we will be able to address it.
And you will have
always double buffering
if you're running in front.
So with that, coming
to the tool itself.
So what can the tool do?
Well, first off it can
actually show how the buffer
is percolating, so the system.
It can show you when memory
was actually being swapped.
It can show you how
busy the CPU and the GPU
is at any point in time.
It can actually show you all
kinds of things-- temperature,
speed, and what-not from
all the different components
inside the system.
And best of all, if you have
some traces inside your code
and you want to see exactly what
happened at [INAUDIBLE] point
in time, you can actually
put them in there
and you can actually see
them and monitor them
there as well so that you
see everything in relation
to each other.
And then you can
actually drill down
and see why you have seen jank.
So with that, let's
come to a sort of demo.
So, let's see.
Let's bring up our tool.
So this tool is--
basically it's a small
particle generator.
And you can see already here--
let me close this guy here.
So you can basically
see the lower line
is 60 frames per
second, the next line
is 30 frames per second,
15, and so on, and so on.
So in order to start the
tool, what I am doing
is I'm pressing Control-Shift-G.
So now tool is running.
And there was also a jank.
Look at that.
That was fast, much
faster than expected.
So let's see.
So first, let's try to
zoom out a little bit
to see the regular pattern.
You can actually see now here--
I hope you can see my cursor.
Yes, you can, awesome.
You can actually see how the
buffer is-- so first off,
we have four buffers here.
So the upper line is always--
and the thing was application
and/or surface [INAUDIBLE]..
The next line is what Chrome
is seeing for its compositor.
And then comes the next
buffer, and the next buffer,
and the next buffer.
So there are lots of buffers.
We had four buffers, it
means quadruple buffering.
So then we have the
Android compositor,
which is doing a
little bit of stuff
before it's actually
passing it onto Chrome
and it's doing something.
And we see Chrome
is also rendering.
And as you can see,
there are two buffers,
which is basically saying
it's using double buffering
at that point in time.
And looking into
the memories thing,
you can actually see how
much memory was being used.
You can see a line creeping
up here, which is--
oh, look at that.
So memory is actually definitely
creeping up over time.
And you can also then see that
the GPU was very busy here.
See?
So there is only a little
bit, and there here
is a pretty solid line.
So let's drill in.
Let's see.
The GL thread was taking longer.
Look at that, OK.
So why was the GL
thread taking more time?
Let's have a look.
There is-- what is this?
I think this is--
the temperature of the
system is incredible.
It's 84 .
Degrees that is
possibly always a reason
why it was actually
going down, because you
are starting possibly
to throttle the system
at that point in time.
But in general, this tool gives
you all the information in one
go.
And you can-- let's
scroll through.
You can see at
the end that there
is composition jank somewhere.
So if you want to see
anything more about this tool,
please come by our Sandboxes.
We have actually people
which we were training
and they are working
on the tool, which
are able to actually
handle anything
inside your application.
If you to see why your
application is janking,
please let us know.
So with that, back
to the slides.
So if you want to
try it on your own,
M75 is going to beta
around today or tomorrow.
So you can actually simply
take the beta channel,
go into developer
mode-- unfortunately
you need developer mode for this
because traces are, of course,
some kind of security risk.
So, therefore, you need to be in
development mode for that one.
And then go into
Settings, Flags,
and say that you want to
use the visualization tool.
And then navigate to this
page to see the result.
For the usage, stop on jank.
Activate that, add your
additional counters
if you want to, and
run your application.
And then once you
are at the point.
Press Control-G, and
see what happens.
You can use w and s
at any point in time
in order to zoom in and
out of the timeline.
Last but not least, we have
updated our documentation.
So if you go online,
you will actually
see how to use the tool.
And we will add more information
there going forwards.
And well, come to our sandbox.
To actually get it done.
With that, I am passing
it on to Emilie.
EMILIE ROBERTS: Thanks, Stefan.
So I'm Emilie Roberts.
I'm a developer advocate
working Chrome OS.
I know many of you,
which is really exciting.
And okie-dokey, so we've learned
a lot about where Chrome OS is
and lots of the new
tools and features
we've brought this year.
I want to talk a
little bit about what
you can do to optimize
your app, what
you can do to make
your apps look awesome
and work really
awesome on Chrome OS.
So I'm going to talk a
little bit about input
and then about output.
And I'm also going
to talk a little bit
about the slash in
the middle, which
is a surprise topic coming up.
So your applications
should support keyboard.
Thanks very much.
Have a good day.
Just kidding.
If you know me, I'd
like to talk a lot.
So I'm going to talk
about a few more things.
Seriously, support
keyboard input--
I know most people
here already do that.
And if you do, the code
looks something like this.
So if I'm looking for
a key up or key down,
I'm looking for the j key.
I do what I want to do.
I return true.
Everything's good.
One little gotcha that
we've seen in a few apps,
don't swallow every key
that the system sends.
So if I'm not
using a key, so I'm
not using any other
keyboard but j here, pass it
back up to Super,
back up to the system.
For example, Chrome
OS might want
to do something
smart with Control-N
and open any window,
or Control-Shift-G
like that tool we just saw,
and run the graphics trace.
If your app is a black hole that
swallows all the key presses,
then it's sad for
the user or else
Chrome OS has to do some tricks.
So pass it up to Super.
Some of you may have noticed
that Chrome OS keyboards have
a Refresh key.
What the heck is up with that?
It's a legitimate key.
It's got his very own key
code and everything, key code
refresh.
So in the web world, it makes
sense to refresh a web page.
But if you think about social
media apps or any content app,
there's also a refresh type
of action that users expect.
And, if there's a refresh key
sitting in front of your users,
well, they're going to
expect when they press it
that your app refreshes.
So you just need
to handle key code
refresh like in
the previous slide
and do the refresh
action in your app.
The good news is, if you're
already using swipe refresh
layout, this will be wired up.
I don't think it's
quite wired up yet,
but it will be wired
up automatically
for you coming forward.
You press Refresh,
that type of layout
will refresh automatically.
Oh, this one's fun.
So if you think about
a mobile operating
system and an app
optimized for that,
and suddenly it's on a laptop
with a touchpad, and stylus,
and all that stuff, it's a super
interesting, wonderful, super
challenging problem
to think about.
Like, how does that happen?
It's cool.
That's why I'm doing
the job I'm doing.
It's super interesting.
So let's talk about a touchpad.
For example, a
user on a desktop,
if they do a two finger
swipe with a touchpad,
they expect the app to scroll.
Well, that's not what
happens in a phone where
it's like a one finger hold
and drag type of motion.
So Chrome OS automatically
wires that up for you.
So most of you
have nothing to do.
The user swipes on the
touchpad and it works.
That's awesome.
That's what we want.
If you're doing
something a little more
tricky with your motion
events, for example
if you're a drawing app,
maybe that scrolling motion
is going to start
drawing on the canvas.
That's just not what you want.
So all you have to do is--
or what works in most
cases, I should say,
check the button state.
If it's zero, no
buttons being pressed,
it's not a drawing event.
And you can just ignore it.
And that should work great.
Okie-dokey, so this
is a super fun game.
It's EA's NBA Live
mobile basketball.
Take a look at it.
It's pretty fun to
play on Chromebooks.
It's a little janky on
the screen, but that's OK.
So take a look at the left,
take a look at the right.
Ea did something
really smart, which
is if a system is
not keeping up,
then it's cutting
out extra animations
and that stuff so that the
actual gameplay is still
going on, which is awesome.
But you'll notice that
poor guy on the left,
his basketballs trailing
along behind him
like a little chihuahua.
He's not really
doing anything cool.
This is select, is the past.
And the right frame is the
current state of things.
It's much more interesting-- the
ball is bouncing up and down,
he's doing those cool moves.
That's what we want to see.
So the issue was
absolutely not EA's.
This game is awesome.
In fact, as I said, I think did
something really intelligent.
The issue was Chrome
OS-- our language
skills weren't that good.
We don't speak ARM that well
for many of our x86 devices.
And so the good news is we've
gone to language school, who
diligently done our homework.
We speak ARM a
little bit better.
So our translation from
ARM to x86 is much better.
So games will
automatically get that.
And there's a lot of new
improvements coming this year
in the pipeline already.
So if you're building
for ARM, good news--
y9ou should see some
improvements in translation.
You'll be able to
do those cool moves.
However, if you care
about performance--
and who doesn't, right--
but especially if you're a game
or a creative app, support x86.
Because all of our top
applications-- or sorry,
our top devices, are x86.
Most of them 64-bit.
The 64-bit
requirement is coming.
And don't throw away ARM 32,
because obviously there's
lots of those devices too.
So ARM 32, ARM 64,
x86-32, x86-64--
sounds like a lot,
but it's actually
quite easy in Android Studio.
And, with Android app bundles,
it bundles it up all nicely,
sends it to the Play Store.
The Play Store will only send
the ABIs that your users need.
So it doesn't increase their
download size or anything
like that.
So thank you very
much, in advance,
for always supporting x86.
Okie-dokey, so
here's the it topic
I'm really excited
about, which is layout.
This is the o--
oh, I didn't tell you.
The slash was the
indicate translation.
So input slash
indicate-- oh, anyway.
So let's talk about layout.
There are mobile
phones, obviously.
But we're moving
a lot beyond that.
There's tablets, there's
Chromebooks, there's foldables,
there's external
monitors, there's TVs,
there's all sorts of things.
Your apps need to work
across all of those devices.
And that's becoming more and
more true as time goes on.
And the ideal
situation is one app
can just fluidly and
seamlessly handle that.
So on a Chromebook, if
I'm resizing your app just
gets bigger, it looks great,
does what it needs to do.
Somebody opens a
foldable, it works great.
Somebody plugs in an external
monitor, it works great.
So this goes a long way.
One approach is to use
different layout buckets
based on screen sizes.
So I'm sure many of
you have seen this.
I hope so.
If not, you can check
out our Resizing Code Lab
in the Code Lab tents.
You have one resource
file and then differently
layout buckets--
landscape, wide
landscape, wide portrait.
Maybe you have six, maybe have
two depending on your layout.
Let's talk about something else,
which is navigation patterns.
So this is how your
users experience
your app, how they get
around your app, how
they explore your content.
Super related to
screen sizes, but I
think it deserves its
own separate topic.
So what happens if you
have a mobile phone app
and you put it on
an external monitor?
It might look
something like this.
It looks horrible.
It looks terrible.
This is a photo viewing app.
And the developer, the
designer should probably
be sent back to
design school, should
be thrown out of the building.
It's me.
So don't throw me
out yet, please.
Give me a second chance.
But you can see that
it's a photo-viewing app.
Maybe on the phone, fine,
you have a 100 photos,
you don't want a
million little previews.
But come on, we've got
lots of screen real estate.
We can do better.
I could literally like
fit inside those columns
with my arms outstretched.
There's so much wasted space.
And most importantly, take
a look at the navigation.
It's all stretched
out, it's tiny.
Can you see what
those icons are?
I doubt it from there, right?
And if you're a visually--
you have some different--
you're a lower vision
user, you're a little bit
far-sighted, you're a normal
person with perfect eagle eye
vision, it's really hard
to see, to understand,
and, if you have
any mobility issues,
to even interact with
those touch targets.
Thumbs down, right?
So I get a second chance.
Here's my second draft.
You can see I did a
little bit better.
It's a photo viewer.
I put a little photo preview
if I have enough space.
Did a little bit
better in the middle.
And most importantly, this
is what I'm talking about,
the navigation is
over on the left.
This is a side navigation.
It's got icons, labels.
They're all close together.
It's easy to navigate for
anybody using the navigation.
That get GitHub link
we'll be live very soon.
If you want to see my amazing
code for this amazing demo,
check it out probably later
this week or next week.
And take a look at the
material design site.
There's lots of great things.
They have a number
of material studies,
which are like toy apps
looking at this stuff.
And they're doing exactly
what I'm talking about.
So they're on a
mobile phone, maybe
they use the bottom navigation.
It's a large landscape.
They've got site navigation
with icons and labels,
and then if it's large
but not so large,
maybe like a rail
navigation on the left.
I want to take just
a second to call out
a really awesome developer we've
worked with this year, Adobe.
As they were optimizing
Adobe Acrobat
for Chrome OS this year, which
meant keyboard input, mouse
input, drag and drop, all
that other great stuff.
They also redesigned
their layout
so it worked really
well on large screens.
So, a mobile phone,
they've got exactly
the same bottom navigation,
which makes sense,
people are used to, works.
But on a larger screen,
moves to the side navigation.
So great work, Adobe, thank you.
And I'm sure your
users thank you, too.
You can check out Adobe Acrobat
and some of their other apps
in our Sandbox tents
or for yourself.
OK, so this is the slide I
inserted as a gift to you.
In case you haven't dived
into Jet Pack yet, please do.
As an Android developer, it's
made my life so much easier.
Thank you very much.
Particularly with what
we're talking about,
particularly all these different
screen sizes, view model,
just makes saving your
state so much easier.
It's a very elegant
way to handle it,
and navigation makes
your fragment headaches
and your pushing and popping
to the fragment set go away.
So d.android.com/jetpack,
check it out.
I think you'll appreciate
it if you don't
know what I'm talking about.
So we're nearing the end.
I wanted to do our
call-out to our code labs.
We have a Resizing Code Lab as
well as Optimizing Code Lab,
which is like keyboard
mouse, drag and drop,
all that fun stuff.
They've been slightly
refreshed for 2019.
So check them out.
And what's cool in
the code lab tent
is you can go into a Chromebook,
develop on the Chromebook
in Android Studio,
like we saw earlier,
and then push it right
to the device, which
is kind of cool as well.
Last but not least, we
have a bunch of sandboxes
all around IO--
so in the Chrome OS
tent, in the gaming tent,
in the Android tent,
we're in Flutter, I think.
Anyway, we're all over.
And you can talk with
the engineers that
are building these products.
We were really fortunate to get
like 40 of the engineers that
work on Chrome OS.
So, if you have questions, go
and talk to them, use them.
Try this stuff out, try
lots of the great apps
we have, and Linux, also known
as Crostini on Chromebooks,
is really improving.
So you can go into
the Chrome OS 10
and look at Developing on
Chromebooks for the Web,
for Android, game development--
we've got Unity running,
which is kind of cool.
And, most importantly--
well, not most importantly--
least importantly, check
out our cool enamel pins.
We have eight of them.
The eighth one, I
think, is super secret.
But we have seven that you can
go in each of the Sandboxes.
They're really cool.
Collect them.
And with that, I think I've
got no more slides left.
Oh, yeah, sorry.
There's my little pin.
That's from the Android Sandbox.
Check it out.
Okie-dokey., so you've learned
a lot about what's going on.
I hope you're excited
about the new tools.
And I hope you're excited
about the enamel pins.
Please think about screen sizes.
Please think about navigation
and keyboard input.
Support x86.
And all these things can help us
support you in the Play Store.
Keep in touch.
Let us know what you're doing.
We're really excited, as always,
to work with the developers
and this great community.
So, thank you for
building on Chrome OS.
Thank you for building
for Chrome OS.
And thanks for your time for
coming here today, and spending
it with us, and
interacting with us after.
We'll be around
in the sandboxes.
And, with that, I've
got to say thank you
to Sweet and Stefan, my
fellow co-presenters.
And thanks again to you.
Talk to you soon.
[LOGO MUSIC]